schritte aus dem shutdown sinkende
zahlen machen hoffnung in immer mehr
regionen gibt es lockerungen rauswurf
aus der partei die grünen wollen
tübingens oberbürgermeister boris palmer
ausschließen wegen eines umstrittenen
kommentare auf facebook und jubel in
madrid alexanders wäre kann erneut
überzeugen und zieht ins atp masters
finale in madrid ein
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg und willkommen an diesem
samstag an meiner seite ist für den
start wo die cern und bayern münchen ist
seit heute deutscher fußballmeister
schönen guten abend
der sommer naht die korona zahlen senken
die hoffnung wächst ab morgen können
sich zumindest schon mal geimpfte und
genesene über lockerungen freuen
für den sommerurlaub hält
gesundheitsminister sparen reisen
innerhalb der eu wieder für möglich
voraussichtlich auch für ungeimpfte
daneben mit tests
das robert koch institut meldet 15 1685
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden das
sind 3250 weniger als vergangenen
samstag die sieben tage incidents sinkt
bundesweit auf 121,5 und fast 160 städte
und landkreise liegen inzwischen unter
100 bleiben sie fünf werktage in folge
unter dieser schwelle sind lockerungen
möglich thomas garcia sanz strand sonne
ein hauch vom sommerurlaub scharbeutz
öffnet und sagt schön dass du da bist
das gilt auch denen die extra angereist
sind endlich wieder essen gehen und ins
hotel
die lübecker bucht ist seit heute
modellregion tests alle drei tage hier
das ticket für freiheiten
auch bundesweit gibt es für geimpfte und
genesene ab morgen etwas normalität und
für alle hoffnung nämlich auf
pfingsturlaub bereits jetzt möglich
tages urlaub in mecklenburg vorpommern
und zwar für zwei mal geimpft
in rheinland pfalz sind ab kommender
woche wieder touristische übernachtungen
möglich in niedersachsen auch erstmal
nur für die niedersachsen selbst in ganz
schleswig-holstein ab dem 17
mai und in bayern kurz vor pfingsten all
das nur bei stabiler incidents unter 100
das testen ist also reisebegleiter wohl
auch im sommer dieses zentrum gehört
zu einem ostseehotel die herberge
ausgebucht der gastgeber ausgelastet
baustellen fertig stellen das personal
aus dem winterschlaf wecken und
zurückholen und alles auf vordermann
bringen nach fast sieben monaten in
denen wir jetzt ganz geschlossen waren
und urlaub im europäischen ausland
könnte auch gehen sagte
gesundheitsminister es sieht eher so aus
dass zumindest mal die hauptpreise
länder nicht unbedingt noch
risikogebiete sind im sommer weiß es
nicht aber in zweifel nordsee statt cc
oder ostsee oder sonst wo nicht mal wie
hauptsache weg deutschland ist
urlaubsreif
und vielleicht bald reisefertig bei
aller mit freude für jeden der schon
geimpft ist mitunter regt sich dann doch
auch ein bisschen neigt das recht wenn
die geimpften und genesenen ab morgen
wieder mehr menschen treffen dürfen
in diesen genuss kommen knapp 7,6
millionen vollständig geimpfte und etwa
2,4 millionen menschen die eine
infektion in den letzten sechs monaten
überstanden haben zusammen ist das mehr
als jeder zehnte in deutschland
melis czekalla berichtet von einer
herdenimmunität ist deutschland noch
weit entfernt doch für geimpfte und
genesene könnte reisen oder im café
sitzen bald wieder zur normalität
gehören erleichterungen sorgen aber auch
für unmut
studien zufolge sind fast die hälfte der
befragten neidisch auf bereits geimpfte
ich finde ungerecht ja eigentlich also
ich persönlich finde ich nicht gerecht
weil halt also es wäre gerecht wenn alle
gleichzeitig kämpfen dürften am anfang
hatte ich da auch eine zweigeteilte
meinungen drüber wenn es darum geht dass
die gesellschaft gespalten wird
aber letztendlich ist es ja wirklich so
dass grundrechte wieder zurückkomme
nicht ganz verstehen dass junge menschen
sagen wir seien solidarisch gegenüber
den alten und jetzt müssen wir zurück
stecken
für den psychologen jens lange sind das
nachvollziehbare emotionen so was wie
die eigene gesundheit oder die eigenen
rechte zurück zu bekommen ist natürlich
etwas was für leute sehr wichtig ist
dadurch ist wahrscheinlich dass leute
darauf eben neidisch reagieren wenn
andere
einen vorteil haben zum beispiel weil
sie bereits geimpft sind
die möglichkeit sich bei ärztinnen auf
eine warteliste setzen zu lassen
um schneller eine impfung zu bekommen
nutzen bereits viele menschen
andere versuchen diese wartezeit zu
umgehen zum beispiel mit gefälschten
pässen in strafrechtlicher hinsicht
natürlich ist es völlig abzuraten von
solche vorgehensweise es hatte sich eine
klare urkundenfälschung die nach
strafgesetzbuch mit geldstrafen und
freiheitsstrafen bis zu fünf jahren
bestraft werden kann
die im freien folge ist deutschlandweit
unterschiedlich geregelt im
einkommensschwachen köln chorweiler
wurde die priorisierung aber aufgehoben
das hatte teilweise für verärgerung
gesorgt es gibt so viele gute gründe
bestimmte menschen jetzt dringend zu
impfen
jetzt sind solche mit dem hohen risiko
schwerer und tödlicher verläufe
das sind solche mit einem hohen
ansteckungsrisiko und das sind solche
mit sozial besonderen situationen und
dazu gehören für mich die sozial
prekären wohnverhältnisse und dazu
gehören für mich auch die jungen
menschen trotz ungerechtigkeitsempfinden
bei einigen jede kurve impfung ist ein
wichtiger schritt aus der krise
die eu setzt noch mehr auf den impfstoff
von baxter und schließt einen vertrag
über weitere 1,8 milliarden dosen 900
millionen als feste bestellung die
andere hälfte sind eine option damit
sollen impfungen von erwachsenen
aufgefrischt und millionen kinder in der
europäischen union gegen das virus
immunisiert werden
besorgt blickt die welt weiter nach
indien von dort kommen neue
erschütternde corona zahlen erstmals
starben nach offiziellen angaben
innerhalb eines tages mehr als 4000
menschen wie dem riesigen land am besten
zu helfen ist auch darum ging es bei
einem video gipfel der eu mit indien das
andere ursprünglich geplante topthema
ist der gemeinsame handel
potenzial gibt es genug mit 1,3
milliarden einwohnern ist indien ein
riesenmarkt aber derzeit nur der zehnte
größte handelspartner der eu anne
gellinek
es ist ein wettlauf mit dem tod im
indischen ahmedabad haben die
gesundheitsbehörden ein drive-in im
zentrum eingerichtet um gegen die hohen
infektionszahlen anzukämpfen
sie können mit jedem fahrzeug ohren
zweirad vierrad oder rikscha und sich
impfen lassen
so wollen wir kontakt und schlange
stehen vermeiden der verzweifelten lage
in seinem land wegen ist premierminister
modi nicht zum eu indien gipfel nach
portugal gereist sondern per video
zugeschaltet die eu hat dem schwer von
corona getroffenen land weitere hilfen
zugesagt bei der freigabe von impfstoff
patenten die neben den usa auch indien
gefordert hatte kommt allerdings eine
deutliche absage aus eu und kanzleramt
wenn hier eine patent freigabe einfach
erfolgt ohne dass sozusagen auch die
qualität jedes mal gut kontrolliert
werden kann sehe ich mehr risiken als
chancen
darüber hinaus wollen die eu und indien
die seit acht jahren auf eis gelegten
gespräche über ein handelsabkommen
wieder aufnehmen
indien fühlt sich vom mächtigen nachbarn
china an den rand gedrängt und ist wohl
auch deswegen bereit erneut mit europa
zu verhandeln network bringt tun das
wird unsere beiden regionen näher
zusammenrücken lassen bei verkehr und
transport aber auch bei der
digitalisierung indien ist ein motor der
digitalisierung einfach werden die
verhandlungen nicht
indien gilt als abgeschotteter markt
doch die beiden größten demokratien der
welt heißt es in der abschlusserklärung
seien immer noch natürliche partner
nach deutschland wieder eigentlich läuft
es bei den grünen gerade prächtig wäre
da nicht boris palmer schon häufiger
fiel der tübinger oberbürgermeister mit
politisch und stritten im aus dem rahmen
auf facebook ist er jetzt zu weit
gegangen finden die grünen
kanzlerkandidaten berbalk nennt seine
äußerungen rassistisch und abstoßend der
landesverband baden-württemberg berlin
aus der partei ausschließen
einmal selbst fühlt sich missverstanden
andreas linke hat mehr
sie wollten sich ein signal des
aufbruchs von ihrem halb digitalen
landesparteitags senden
dem koalitionsvertrag mit der cdu
stimmten suters delegierten mit großer
mehrheit zu
aber mehr aufmerksamkeit zog mal wieder
boris palmer auf sich der tübinger
oberbürgermeister hatte sich in der
debatte rund um dienst lehmann und
dennis aogo auf facebook zu wort
gemeldet und selber rassistische
begriffe verwendet kanzlerkandidatin
annalena baerbock antwortete schnell
deutlich die äußerung von boris palmer
es rassistisch und abstoßend das ganze
reiz sich einen immer neue provokationen
die menschen ausgrenzen und verletzten
palmer betonte die ironie seine
einlassungen und begrüßte dass das
parteischiedsgericht das jetzt
beurteilen sollte dass er weiterhin
davon überzeugt dass die partei brauche
ungeschickten den mann absichtlich
falsch versteht und menschen eine
haltung an dichter die sie gar nicht
haben
mit seiner test und öffnungs strategie
hatte er zuletzt positive schlagzeilen
erzeugt der tübinger oberbürgermeister
bis heute ich finde es auch eines
oberbürgermeisters unwürdig dauern mit
provokationen zu polarisieren und es
dann irgendwie als ironie zu erklären
ist ja ein profi
dann weiß man ironie funktioniert nie in
der politik ein parteiinterner streit
mitten in der grünen aufbruchstimmung
nach israel
das land kommt nicht zur ruhe wieder gab
es im ostteil jerusalems zusammenstöße
zwischen polizei und palästinensern
und wieder gab es verletzte auf beiden
seiten seit tagen protestieren
palästinenser weil ihnen die
zwangsräumung ihrer wohnungen droht aus
israel berichtet michael warum die al
aksa moschee auf dem jerusalemer
tempelberg 1 für muslime und juden
gleichermaßen heiliger die umkämpfte ort
zu den schweren zusammenstößen kam es
nach dem traditionellen freitagsgebet
palästinenser werfen steine flaschen und
feuerwerkskörper
die polizei geht mit gummigeschossen und
blendgranaten gegen die demonstranten
vor über 200 von ihnen werden verletzt
die polizei berichtet von 17 verletzten
auf ihrer seite
auslöser des konflikts ist die
siedlungspolitik
der plan ist ganz jerusalem zu besetzen
sagt diese palästinensische frau und
daraus ethnisch eine rein jüdische stadt
zu machen ohne arabische präsenz kern
der aktuellen spannungen ist der streit
um grundstücke im ostjerusalemer
stadtteil shake schach
dort droht fast 30 palästinensischen
familien die zwangsräumung ein nach
israelischem recht jüdische ansprüche
aus der zeit vor der staatsgründung 1948
bestehen die familie von mohammad al-
code ist eine der betroffenen
wir gehen nirgendwo hin die leute in
sheikh jarrah kommen aus der
arbeiterklasse
sie können sich nicht einfach etwas
woanders leisten sollten sie
zwangsgeräumt werden
warum sollten wir auch daran denken das
ist unser zuhause wir werden es nie
verlassen
für die israelische regierung ist es
offiziell ein streit unter privat
parteien die entscheidung des obersten
gerichtshofs steht noch aus usa und eu
riefen heute alle parteien zur mäßigung
auf unterdessen hat die hamas den
protest an und versucht den konflikt
gegen israel auszuweiten
sie hat zu einem tag des zorns an der
israelischen grenze zu gaza aufgerufen
eine eskalation der gewalt ist nur noch
schwer zu verhindern
die evangelische kirche in deutschland
hat heute geschichte geschrieben statt
einer politikerin wählte sie eine
unbekannte junge studentin zur präses
mit 25 ist anna nicole heinrich die
bislang jüngste in diesem spitzenamt
ganz abgesehen davon zwingt auch corona
die kirche zu neuen wegen zum beispiel
zu gottesdiensten aus dem eigenen
wohnzimmer fabian köhler
wenn wir jetzt diese andacht feiern im
namen des vaters und des sohnes und des
heiligen geistes online andacht live
gestreamt ins netz das heimische
wohnzimmer die kleine ersatz kirche von
pastorin hanna jacobs seit monaten
finden in der epiphanias gemeinde in
hannover kaum noch präsenz gottesdienste
statt die andacht am pc nahezu normal
ich bin erstaunt darüber wie gut das
doch auch mit älteren menschen
funktioniert dass man menschen in meinem
alter darüber erreichen kann und sich
austauschen kann das war mir irgendwie
klar aber es gibt ganz viele großmütter
die sind 80 85 die haben auch ein
smartphone und skypen darüber nur wenige
kilometer weiter ebenfalls digital die
synode der ekd kirche in zeiten der
pandemie ein thema der online tagung die
frisch gewählte neue vorsitzende des
kirchenparlamente sanaa nicole heinrich
25 jahre alt eine hoffnungsträgerin auch
um die evangelische kirche digitaler zu
gestalten
wirkliche die mutig ist und mal was sagt
und ich glaube genau so eine wahl ist
ein richtiges zeichen dass ich mir das
nicht nur wünsche sondern dass die
kirche in der ich mich super gerne
engagiert mutig ist und was sagt und ich
hoffe dass das auch menschen inspirieren
wird sich mit der institution noch
einmal neu auseinanderzusetzen wenn man
sie da verändert sich was in der
gemeinde von pastor in jacobs hat das
digitaler auch schon viele fans die
mitglieder sehen auch vorteile
leider können wir einfach zu hause
bleiben und in jogginghose dasitzen und
wir finden das eigentlich schön dass so
die kirche zu uns nach hause kommt
online kirche zu hause kein ersatz für
jeden gottesdienst aber ein zugewinn für
viele gläubige mit fußball geht es los
an diesem samstag bayern münchen darf
schon feiern vorzeitig dank einer
niederlage von verfolger rb leipzig hat
sich der deutsche rekordchampion
vorzeitig die deutsche fußball
meisterschaft gesichert
hier sind die samstags ergebnisse vom
drittletzten bundesliga-spieltag
dortmund macht mit dem 3 2 sieg gegen
leipzig die bayern zum meister
hoffenheim nach 0 2 rückstand 4 zu 2
gegen schalke wolfsburg union berlin 3
zu 0 alle drei tore durch brekalo ein
punkt für werder bremen im abstiegskampf
0 zu 0 gegen leverkusen
ausführlich das spiel bayern münchen
gegen mönchengladbach im sportstudio
gestern stuttgart augsburg zwei zu eins
in der tabelle bayern münchen verleibt
sich nicht von leipzig nicht mehr
einzuholen die neunte meisterschaft
nacheinander ist besiegelt wolfsburg
weiter auf champions-league-kurs
dortmund und eintracht frankfurt
tauschen zumindest bis morgen die plätze
die zweite hälfte beginnt mit sc
freiburg keine veränderungen bis zum 14
werder bremen vorübergehend vor hertha
bsc bielefeld auf dem relegationsplatz
vor köln schalke steht ja als absteiger
fest die krise des deutschen
fußball-bundes ist am abend unter
anderem thema bei uns im aktuellen
sportstudio zu gast vizepräsident rainer
koch und deutschlands topspieler
alexander zverev steht im finale des
tennis atp masters in madrid einen tag
nach seinem sieg gegen rafael nadal
gewinnt er mit 6 3 und 6 4 gegen den
österreicher dominik team
er spielt sein bestes tennis und damit
bezwingt alexanders wäre es nun auch den
zweiten höher gesetzten gegner ein break
gelingt ihm schon früh im ersten satz
entscheidend sind starke aufschläge und
ein konstant hohes spielniveau
es wäre es macht die entscheidenden
punkte und gewinnt den ersten satz mit 6
zu 3 gegen den us-open-sieger team
die kombination aus kraft und feingefühl
beim matchball zum 6 4
es ist erst der zweite erfolg auf sand
über seinen freund aus österreich
schwere fahrt morgen die chance seinen
turniersieg von 20 18 zu wiederholen und
formel 1 rekord weltmeister lewis
hamilton erreicht einen weiteren
meilenstein in seiner karriere
im qualifying zum großen preis von
spanien in barcelona fährt er zum
hundertsten mal auf die pole position
es ist eine besondere zahl dank erneut
starker leistung von lewis hamilton in
einer spannenden qualifikation ist der
mercedes pilot am ende nur 36
tausendstelsekunden schneller als sein
großer rivale max verstappen im red bull
ich kann es nicht glauben dass es jetzt
100 sind sebastian vettel im aston
martin auf rang 13 wird es schwer haben
erstmalig die punkteränge zu fahren
zufrieden dagegen mit schumacher r
startet morgen in barcelona von position
18 im unterlegenen haas so viel von mir
vom sport dankeschön bitte 30 grad
wenn du schon gewusst dass wir ihnen
morgen morgen 30 grad angekündigt mehr
dazu hat gleich erst intelli marietta
slomka freut sich auch sie im heute
journal um viertel vor elf und wir
freuen uns wenn sie morgen wieder dabei
sind
danke für ihr interesse einen schönen ab
noch und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter nun kommt sie die
warme luft aus dem süden europas sie
wird vor diesem tief bei den britischen
inseln
herr angesaugt und dreht dann regelrecht
auf süd die temperaturen morgen dann im
südwesten bis 30 grad
schauen wir es in die kommende nacht da
gibt es ganz im norden regen
der zieht allmählich nach osten hin ab
sonst klart es bis in den süden
teilweise auf und im südosten sinken die
temperaturen bis auf plus 1 grad und 12
grad im westen da ist es am mildesten
morgen den ganzen tag viel sonnenschein
vor allem in der südhälfte nach norden
gibt es einige wolken mehr und im westen
ziehen schauer durch zum abend kann es
auch mal richtung nordsee gewittern kann
auch mal kräftiger ausfallen und die
temperaturen ziehen stark an 30 grad im
südwesten deutschlands verbreitet
sommertag ist angesagt also temperaturen
über 25 grad nur im osten nicht und
entlang der küsten 20 grad gibt es an
der nordsee und die kommenden tage
es geht im osten deutschlands am montag
heißt weiter bis 30 grad von westen her
erreichen uns schauer und gewitter und
danach kühlt es allerdings wieder ab
damit ein schöner abend